نحن الان امام المدخل الرئيسي للمؤسسه كما
يظهر خلفي هنا حصل اجتماع البارحه بين
اللمسك وبين العاملين
[موسيقى]
هو طالب العديد منهم طلبهم بالقدوم الى
المراكز الرئيسيه هنا في سان فرانسيسكو في
مراكز اخرى حول العالم
هذا اثر كثيرا طبعا هناك ايضا خلاف حول
رؤيه له ماسك الموظفون يرفضون رؤيته
يرفضون
السياسات الجديده المتعلقه بالمحتوى
[موسيقى]
حتى الان العدد الذي عرفنا به الذي استقال
البارحه تقريبا هو 1,200 موظف هو عدد كبير
في الحقيقه في ظل اقتراب كاس العالم وفي
ظل المخاوف تزايد المخاوف من حدوث القطاع
خلال ايام القادمه خاصه خلال كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
الممثله شدد على انه مع حريه التعبير
ويقول طبعا هو يبرد ذلك بانه لم يسمح
بالا خطاب الكراهيه واي تغريده
تضمن او تشمل خطاب كراهيه لن يسمح
بالترويج لها ولكنه لم يمنعها هذا ما قاله
ولكن في المقابل الكثيرون يرفضون هكذا